of a back to back we've seen that burn the Devils
a few times as Year guys get caught out for long
shifts they're tired that's when the mental errors
kind of boil up so we'll see if the Devils can
keep their shifts short and get off to strong
starts again as Lazar puts it on John Gibson a
winning hockey games duck still without Trevor zes
he's injured Mason Mavish not back from an injury
yet either here's Jack Hughes for the Devils he's
in he shs and he's shot is denied by gibsy leushin
pressured by Lazar Michael McLoud gets to it Puck
rolls toward the blue line or shimone Nemitz keeps
it in it's McLoud working the goal line Bastion
feeds here's a drive on from Sean ther it's behind
Gib he's been one of the real good coaches in this
league for for a long time comes to bot in front
he shoots and Gibson cuts down the angle has to
be a feeling of sheer Terror to be a goalie and
you think you've got it covered but the whistle
doesn't come and you know it's just sitting there
somewhere good pass ahead to jper Brady streaks in
and Gibson's got him again the red line offensive
zone draw coming for the Devils they'll send
out the teimo Meer Nico heer and Andre Pat line
you you see the Jer brat opportunities he's
he's in behind and it's Alex clor back not a
defenseman Jacob silverberg back for stro again
Fowler settles he moves it one timer vrono and
Aira Schmid makes his first save of the night
Terry forward looking for Sam Carrick and Akira
Schmid comes out to play it away minov Glides
it sent through the goal mouth it was looking
for Carrick minov cranks it again save Schmid
off the right pad and Ross Johnson who's much
more experienced from the fistic cup standpoint
that's you know really his main role but you
understand it turned over to H Gibson makes an
Immaculate save well be saying heck of a save
as the puck has turned over right to Paula and
that was the blast right in the slot and look at
Gibson Bo Jack's been all over
the ice in this first period now
Meer blast kick save neon out on the
rebound poot shot doesn't [Applause]
go minute 30 to go on the power play Jack shoots
save Gibson Nico for brat and it's off the post
you're going to get some outnumbered situations
he committed on trying to make a make contact one
more shift for Jack Hughes in the per and he
streaks to a goal and Gibson makes a shoulder
save the National Hockey League in the Devils
Henri backand and Schmid shrugs it away with
his shoulder 18 seconds left on the power play
sent toward the front it trickles in mov throw
it to the doorstep and Adam Henri deflex it in
for a duck go oh Devils were pressing up high in
Adam Henrik but they couldn't get to mikov
in time right here he gets a lad to Henrik
and Beautiful redirection by the former devil
right between the wickets of akir Schmid you
see how he changes that puck goes merer on the
loose Puck H at teas up the blue line now it's
Luke Hughes Sweeping in Luke to the front he
shoots and Gibson kicked it out ball triggers
it it's blocked it bounces and it goes wide
all kinds of bodies in front here's a great
move by Luke Hughes gets to the net losing an
edge or not M you he couldn't put it home wow
he broke in quickly and I think he hit the
outside of the post on the back hand he just
lost control another chance for mov kicks but
Henrik there on the rebound and it's two nothing
Ducks Adam Henri just well he's done all his
career by the New Jersey Lottery remember anything
can happen in Jersey and there's mikov with the
opportunity and Schmid makes the initial save
but Henrik good position as he's right there to
just clean up the rebound into the empty net and
now Anaheim has a two nothing lead that New Jersey
Lottery million dollar they get the first few Jack
Hughes slides it across for T foi is pass broken
up by Cam Fowler now Anaheim charges the other
way with Troy Terry Terry in the slot he delays
he shoots he hits the post well that was close
Devil's going three on two def Foley's in the
zone defley rips he hits the post as well Dead
on post he whipped that wrist shot Terry's looked
like a little more of the outside of the post but
boy that would have been a great response
going the other way after Anam almost made
it three nothing final 45 seconds Lazard Michael
McLoud pulls the DI [Music] [Applause] one with
a really nice play as you see the punch turn
turned over and look at the backhand pass by
Lazar to McLoud nice poke check there just inside
his own Zone by Sean th that starts the whole play
McLoud with a Nifty pass to Lazar Lazar back
hands it right back to kind of come out in the
first four minutes and the third period and been
the aggressor oh boy I thought that puck in as
NT lost it yeah rolled right to Akira Schmid who
kept it out out LOM across and that is jammed in
Alex color makes it 31 off a diagonal beauty of
a pass from Jackson lome W this is just careless
you know a little disorganized to start this
third period and it's surprising after they got
that late goal to make it a one goal game but you
see right here as colorin is wide open and he's
not going to have an easier one than that R and
Hughes wins it good stick by Max Jones knock it
away from John Marino Jones all the way through
toward the front Puck sitting there Schmid gets
a piece and he covers the rebound blacks in front
as well there's a nice stick right there that's
hard to the net there's Marino trying to Ward him
off and then another pulk at it from Brock mcin
well ducks come close to maybe Luke finds Meer
his shot is blocked by The Stick of Troy Terry
this is where Anaheim up a couple of goals
can can be responsible in the middle of the
ice that goes in WoW Meer had broken his stick
he was going to the bench Troy Terry coming the
other way puts it home to make it 41 Bo made
their shots count this is this is the bread
and brother of Troy Terry shifts are periods
but you give him time and space and he can Let
Her Fly let's take a look at this replay brought
to you by the local Tri-State Buick dealers and
this is a wicked Rous shot as Terry lets it go
up top far too much time for him to let this go
and this is one of those games where Anaheim has
made everything count yep everything he's got a
got to find a sparkk and get some confidence
going M Cloud wins the face off second unit
out HTS a big drive safe do rebound still hasn't
gone comes back to Holz and skips over him it's
a foot race Henrik already has two and now
he has his first career hatrick and he does
it back in [Music] [Applause] Jersey well that
will certainly seal it you would think it just
hasn't been the devil's night and Anaheim
you give them credit they've they've been
fresh there's the bouncing Puck uh on the pass
from Mercer bounc right over the blade he got
a little piece of it and Adam Henry skates right
under it and an easy one for him for the hattick
and shut the door as well and they combined to
stop 28 of 29 devil shots Devils fall to one
five and one on the back half of backto backs
and they lose a nasty one with the Ducks 51